a tenth Commissioner of baseball will be
there and is kindly calling into the
Rich Eisen show once again Rob Manfred
back here on the show how are you
commissioner I'm great rich you know I
have a solution for your head where
issue okay
they have World Series merchandise in
this date nice and it's good for the
economics of the game just buy yourself
a World Series head it'll look great on
you but I'm a member of the media
Commission I expect things for nothing
is that a problem
can I tell you something if you really
want the head out get me your seat I'll
have one delivered well I'll just tell
you right now I'm the couple over from
malaria King neutral undertaking is a
great way to put it the Commissioner of
baseball joining us here on the Rich
Eisen show so was that too quick last
night was that too fast for your like
I'm sort of believing and there's no
such thing as too quick I think last
night was a really well paced game it
was exciting it was well played and you
know III think it's an example of how
the game can be played okay and then the
first pitch last night was a special one
let's talk about that ceremonial first
pitch the family of Jackie Robinson out
there and I know I'm sure you go way
back with this family what was that like
to see that moment in Dodger Stadium
last night for you well I think it was
really a wonderful moment hats off to
the Dodgers in terms of taking the lead
on that one you know they said it in the
introduction so I'm gonna steal somebody
else's line but you know Rachel really
is a treasure for our game you know
Jackie's legacy is you know a crucial
part of baseball's history and why it's
so one into the fabric of American
culture and she's really carried on
techies like to see through the Jackie
Robinson foundation for literally
decades so it's a great moment and then
I couldn't help but notice says
everybody has watching the games about
the hash tag
that the league is behind similar to the
NFL in support of hurricane relief what
was your role when hurricane Harvey blew
through Houston and the Astros were
nomads for for quite some time
Commissioner well we had two important
things that we were focused on first of
all you know because of the nature of
our game we had to figure out exactly
how Houston was going to complete their
schedule in a timely way and and
obviously that the foremost concern
there is don't want to have an impact on
the competition on the field hats off to
the Rays for hosting Houston for the
games that they couldn't play in Houston
really sort of a collegial act on the
part of the Tampa Club and then secondly
of course really interested in the issue
of hurricane relief Major League
Baseball made a million dollar donation
for Houston relief and you know you know
we worked very closely with Jim crane
and the Astros what the Astros locally
was phenomenal I think they did four
million dollars in relief and and
instead of just making a donation Jim in
the Astros really took a leadership role
in the community in terms of defining
the programs that the Astros and a
sponsor and and determining how they X
four million dollars was going to be
spent Rob Manfred the 10th Commissioner
of Major League Baseball darling in to
the show in between games 1 and 2 here
in Los Angeles
I do want to talk with you about a
couple of rules changes that have been
made that we saw take roost in a way
during the playoffs that some people
fans have had issues with including the
manager the Chicago Cubs Joe Maddon in
particular it was that play where the
Buster Posey rule came into play at home
plate and it was properly called but it
was the convergence of player safety and
instant replay all at once to take a run
away in a play that for over a hundred
years looked like good old hard clean
baseball is there any sort of sense
amongst ownership membership and perhaps
your office
about changing that rule absolutely none
I think Joe Maddon is a minority of one
on this particular issue he has a
pattern has a habit of doing this with
his life the Cubs were warned about it
before they went into the playoffs and
you know I think the rule has been
really successful and that we have not
had a single serious home plate
collision that resulted in the catcher
was missing a material amount of time
and that was more important than whether
they get one run in one game hmm
so there won't be any there's not even a
scintilla of discussion about this I
mean you know others in Joe's Congress I
am not aware of anyone who supports
revisiting the issue of the home plate
rule and then there was the issue of
instant replay that again it was a
proper call upon further review of Jose
Lobaton foot just popping off the base
at a crucial moment in that divisional
series between the Cubs and the
Nationals and again it was one of those
moments that again folks thought maybe
there should be a change in the rule to
make sure that players can feel safe
going back into a bag that there
shouldn't be penalized for a hard slide
to try and remain safe going back into a
bag is there any thought about changing
that way of reviewing a play
commissioner we you know I'm actually
kind of proud to say that our baseball
operations group at the time Tony
LaRussa dilatory and Peter would work
when we were putting the replay rule
together they actually raised in a
number of meetings the fact that replay
was going to discrete make obvious
things that are not cool right now and
and the pre replay I mean and the simple
way Dave was the runner coming off the
base and you know we had long
discussions about that and you know the
conclusion we came to is this year than
I have an instant replay you have to
call what you see on the replay
he struck dumb pyres to ignore some
things that they say and call others
it's not the way rules can be applied
and so while I understand it's a little
bit hunt play has caused a change in
this area I think it's a change that we
foresaw and that we were prepared to
accept given the fact that you know the
vast majority of people wanted us to go
to instant replay okay so are you
thinking of widening the number of plays
that can be reviewed or keeping it
static what is your thoughts on moving
forward Commissioner look I think that
we have about the right mix of plays
that are subjective play review I would
be reluctant to expand we played two
additional plays I think you know we
play has an effect on pace of aim
another issue that obviously we're
concerned about so where we are right
now okay and then in terms of one last
thing with replay Commissioner certainly
in this day and age where things get
more and more confusing what when
something is either reviewable or not or
when it is reviewable when someone sees
it as they see it sitting on their couch
somebody at league headquarters or
somewhere within the stadium sees it
differently
why are you planning on having the
umpires be miked up like NFL officials
to describe exactly why they're going
underneath the headsets and what they
see with in the same way that NFL
officials and college football and NHL
officials do is there any movement for
that you know we've talked about the
need or additional explanations with
respect to replay we do make available
to broadcasters an explanation of what
went on with respect to the call the
idea putting umpires on microphone we
have talked about and frankly of
rejected on the idea
it'll just lengthen the replay review
process and again be another delay in
the game that were not anxious to bite
into
okay well I'm you know I'll put just
again my two cents
I I'd love to hear the explanation
sometimes because instead of just
pointing at a spot in the field or at a
player and then making it out or a safe
call it seems to be a lot more nuanced
than that I'd love to get an explanation
as a fan yeah there are some look there
are some calls where an explanation will
be good and what was X I talked about
explanations being provided I'm
scoreboards and things like that I think
that's a more realistic solution from a
timing perspective than the umpire
getting out of microphone okay maybe Joe
West could make a song out of it you
know you want to lengthen anything but
he maybe could sing maybe you could sing
out you know play stands is called or
something like that well that would have
some I'm just trying to I'm just always
trying to improve the game Commissioner
you know that you know that all right
thanks for calling in in between games 1
and 2 and again I don't I don't know my
hat size but I would be more than
anything adjustable I'll take that for
sure ok and we will make that me too
thanks commissioner we'll stay at the
game we'll see you at the game you guys
you guys it's commissioner Rob Manfred
for more Rich Eisen show tuned to
audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Rich Eisen show app